thanks for the introduction thank you
all for coming
um I had a nightmare this morning that I
got here and then my laptop broke down
and then once we fixed that I was
standing here and was wearing my pajamas
it's terrible so I'm very excited to be
here with functioning laptop and no
pajamas
and talk to you about Basic Marketing
science solving marketing's three
biggest problems
as we already established on Thomas I uh
it's my mission to bring Bayesian
modeling to its fullest potential and I
started this when I was in grad school
at Brown and found that Bayesian
modeling is a really amazing tool to
solve all kinds of Applied problems and
build custom models to solve these
problems and however there are still and
were back then even more things standing
in the way of those widered options and
that started with the tooling and it's
why I got involved with some other folks
like responders back to develop pymc
and then during my work at quantopian
which was a Quant Finance Company
I also discovered that it was not only
really useful for academic research but
also for solving applied business
problems and then after
that chapter ended I started Ponzi labs
to really dry try and bring this to
establish it in business
so
privacy Labs is basically a bunch of the
people that have developed Pine C and
joined the development team over the
years to help companies use pimc more
effectively or just solve any kind of
problem where Bayesian might be a good
fit
and I couldn't be more
happy about the the team that I'm
working with like these are some of the
most talented amazing modelers I've ever
had the pleasure of working with which
is also what I like to call them the the
Bayesian Avengers uh because each one of
them is especially in their own way and
in hardcore
we work with clients from all over the
industry
and solved their problems and so for
example hellofresh you probably know
them uh they're also here in Berlin
we help them with some media mixed
modeling marketing attribution uh visual
vest there's a company also here in
Germany with custom lifetime value
modeling so you see uh there's
definitely a large exposure of marketing
companies marketing departments in
e-commerce companies that were helping
and
that was a bit surprising to us because
none of us really had a marketing
background and nonetheless there was
this huge demand there so marketing does
seem to be very eager to adopt these
methods and the other big branch of
companies that we're working with are
Healthcare biotech companies which I
guess also makes sense because a lot of
us have a biotech background and also
because it's often much closer
Associated to academic research where
basement modeling is a bit more
established
uh but we're not limited to this so we
work with um all kinds of companies
so I want to start this talk by
introducing our protagonist Amy uh I
generated her on this person does not
exist
um she is the VP of data science at an
e-commerce company
and she is of course uh not an island
but embedded in the whole organization
and has certain uh well requirements and
people that provide inputer and certain
resources so I wanted to map out that
and see what challenge she has and then
what I think the market needs and what
we developed to help people like Amy in
the marketing space
so there's the CFO right and he said he
or she sets revenue and profitability
targets uh
and also of course has a probably a
pretty tight grip on the budget so Amy
can't just go out and buy software
Solutions uh for every little problem
that she has she will have to develop
Solutions herself right
and of course like any
retail or e-commerce company marketing
will probably be the biggest expense in
the business and a large effort is going
to be placed on that so really it's very
important to maximize the marketing
return on investment
uh the other team that she's working
with closely is the CMO slash the
marketing team and what they really want
is to maximize the efficiency of their
marketing budget
and towards that goal what they want is
accurate measurements of all their
different efforts right so they're
asking data science to help them measure
the things that they're doing
and one complexity well several
complexities with that but one is that
they have all kinds of diverse different
data sets so they have data sets on the
marketing
dollars that they're spending on
different channels they tracking the new
users that are coming in the sales that
they're doing they're launching
campaigns and they want to know the
impact of those they have lift tests so
just all kinds of different data sets
and somehow out of that
stuff they need to form a coherent
picture right and that's what they're
asking data science to do
but not only a Korean picture but also
insights that are transparent and
actionable
and things that they're often are
looking for and these are these three
things uh what are my customer
acquisition costs how much do you have
to spend in marketing to get a single
customer
as well as once I have acquired that
customer how much do I earn from the
customer right the customer lifetime
value
and then other things related to for
example campaigns is or any type of
action that they're doing what is the
effect of that what is the causal impact
of the actions that we're taking
so these are the asks
um of Amy but also there is a uh they're
all resources that she has so for
example
she will have a data science team
working for her and
probably many of you will be familiar
with what that is I assume most of you
are data scientists who are working in
uh in a group like that or are at a
different level and there's often a lot
of pressure to produce results fast
right so the marketing team wants those
reports and insights for this quarter
this deadline and that makes it
difficult to really come up with
long-term r d strategy to say okay well
now we're going to build like a huge
amazing statistical model that
incorporates all these different data
sources and attributes uncertainty in
the right way so
that compounded with the fact that it's
very hard to find these statistical
modeling experts in the market makes
that pretty challenging
and another challenge of course is that
most data scientists are not themselves
experts in marketing right so there's
sort of a domain expert problem where
the knowledge is differently located in
the company
and then any solution that the data
science team comes up with
needs to be deployed and so they will go
to the data engineering team and they
really care about things like
maintainability and being able to run
these things on premise and things like
that
okay so this is after having worked at
pimsy Labs with in many of those
settings I think we have provided some
tools that will hopefully help Amy and
and people like her
and that is what up here the primesy
labs open source marketing stack
consisting out of currently causal pi
and piency marketing which are the tools
that I will be talking more about
so a key tenant and
because you came to the stock you'll
probably know that we'll talk about
Bayesian modeling and they have many
benefits but one of them is that they
are inherently transparent in what they
do right so there is a model graph and
you can explain this to your
stakeholders to the marketing people of
how your inputs relate to your outputs
and that of course is very important
when you want to build trust but not
only can you explain the model you can
also explain the results right so the
parameters are not some
crazy uh thing in a very high
dimensional space some embeddings but
rather there are parameters that relate
to things that you actually want to
estimate right so for example customer
lifetime value
also this stack is open source which I
think is very important and this is also
what I think is the big difference right
there's many media mix models out there
that people sell for hundreds of
thousands in annual licensing costs
which of course is a quite a big drain
on on any budget so obviously it's free
which is cool uh it's transparent you
can look at the code if you just get a
SAS solution you don't really know they
tell you all that their model is state
of the art amazing but how can you
really verify what it's really doing
it's modifiable so you can just use that
code as a template and do your own thing
or inherit from That Base Class right
and build your own custom model
and of course it integrates with the pi
data stack so your data scientists will
love it because it you can use it with
pandas and Jupiter and the engineers
hopefully you will like it too because
it you can just like deploy it in-house
and airflow and use kubernetes and all
these other deployment tools that are
out there
now one Central problem that we've come
across over and over again in pimc labs
in
trying to solve these problems is that
every customer is very very different so
we in the beginning we thought when we
did this once we were like okay cool now
we can just like do the same thing for
everyone but we found that's not at all
what it is so we always needed to do
custom Solutions which is what we're
mainly doing right we're coming into the
company and helping them solve their
very particular problem so we found that
it was pretty much impossible to build
like a one-size-fits-all solution that
has like everything in one tool so
rather I think the Unix principle uh
will come into play or it will be
helpful here where you have simple tools
that you can combine simply which makes
sense if if we're talking about like an
ecosystem of tools that are compatible
with each other
and then build your own custom workflows
around that
also that idea from the Tidy verse right
uh where you have all these individual
tools and they just speak the same
language so this is really the vision
behind this
and of course developed by the base and
Avengers
um so the modeling is uh is legit but
also as I said we're not marketing
experts ourself but we teamed up with
domain experts that have done this for
many many years
so
privacy marketing uh is something that
we just released so I'm very excited to
announce this here and tell you a little
bit more about it so it is as I already
said Bayesian so built on Pine c
um which is a probabilistic programming
package for python that allows you to
build these
fairly complex statistical Bayesian
models
and it's open source Apache V2 licensed
so just do whatever you want with it use
it in commercial selling set it sell it
whatever and we pride ourselves on
uh having made time c as user friendly
as possible not to say that's very user
friendly but we try
um so we try to extend this here to
Primacy marketing and just give
user-friendly high level API that is
easy to use
it comes with two models that are
commonly used in marketing media mix
models and customer lifetime value
models we plan to add more but that's
where we started
and in that it's the success of the
lifetimes Library if you're familiar
with this so This was done by cam
Davidson and he I think mostly abandoned
this so people were looking for new
solutions to do customer lifetime value
models
and that's what we provide and also
doing it in a Bayesian framework so this
is the UL check it out and also a big
shout out to the people who helped us
develop this
um domain experts uh Juan did a lot of
work on this also with the code uh he's
the data scientist as Walt
um and there's a lot of experience with
this called Ellen was largely
responsible for the customer lifetime
value stuff
Niall Alton and Luca fiaski they just
have a Decades of experience in this
space so yeah we really tried and not
only do what we as statisticians think
is the right thing but also uh what what
people told us what they need
uh if you're more interested in learning
about this there's a webinar today
actually
um where you can sign up just go to meet
up I'm see labs and then you can find it
but I wanted to talk a little bit more
about Bayesian models uh and and why
that is so powerful in marketing but
also specifically for the problems that
we're trying to solve here
so one of them is the ability to set
constraints on modeling parameters using
priors so this is extremely helpful when
working with other stakeholders because
you can just get the input so you can
ask them well what do you think in
general like a rough parameter range of
the customer lifetime value is they will
already have several ideas on that right
so they have been doing this for many
many years and you don't have to throw
away that domain expertise because you
have your black box machine learning
model that just learns everything from
data you can take the input and enter
into a conversation with them and really
get the download from them and
co-develop like a model with them that
all that also really helps to
um well make people adopt your Solutions
related to this we can incorporate
existing knowledge about effects of
advertising so not only by asking people
but also from other data sources so for
example if we have run a b tests or lift
tests we can incorporate that to get
better estimates and this is the idea
behind this that we have these diverse
data sets and we ideally want to come up
with a Korean picture that takes all of
those into account
also because we're in a Bayesian
framework and the inference algorithms
by now have been very have become very
very powerful we can just build whatever
crazy model we want and usually the
sampler will have no huge issues
sampling everything that you put into
your model so for example the robin
model has a very sophisticated fitting
structure with iterative optimization
and some evolutionary algorithms just
because if you
don't have price and UI in this very
difficult statistical modeling space
fitting these irons can be challenged
but fortunately primes that's the
strength of Pi MC right that it just
like code your model and then we try and
figure it out for you
and
finally the idea that we produce
generative models
so the benefit of that is that once we
fit the model we can just generate new
data creating forecasts we can use that
for model validation to see does it
actually replicate the data that I know
that I used to fit this with but also
things like scenario analysis like what
if I doubled my marketing spend so this
generative framework is very powerful
for this
so what are media mix models well
um they start with a certain Media
budget that you allocate and then you
want to know how effective each
marketing channel is so you have a total
budget you get a certain number of
activations or sign ups and from that
you can back out the customer
acquisition costs there's
a lot more Nuance to this like transfer
functions but this is the core of it
so let's look at an example that was
provided by Juan and we have two
marketing channels in our example and
over time we spend
a certain amount which is normalized
here to be between 0 and 1. and on the
output side we measure how many sales we
got right so we want to know how do our
marketing efforts Drive sales
now with privacy marketing this is we
try to make this as simple as possible
you just call the delayed saturate mmm
class you instantiate it you pass in all
these different things
so you see well we have a Target output
column we have a date column
the channel columns you can have certain
control columns you see these sine and
cosine these are the Fourier bases to
model seasonality effects we can include
certain events like Christmas
um and then parameters for other
transfer functions in the model
so with this single line and then to fit
it you just call Dot fit
you build a model that's actually fairly
complex right so I'm not going to go
through this but we have the likelihood
here we have inputs we have parameters
for transfer functions and everything
that goes into an mmm so you can just
imagine that if you were to write this
from hand using pi MC it would probably
be quite an effort and there's many
tutorials out there and talks and people
asking questions how do I do this so
here we just try it and do this for you
that
it's just out of the box
when you fit this the first thing you
want to do is probably just see what the
how good is it that's replicating your
data so this is called a posterior
predictive check and in blue we have
what the model predicts and in Black we
have the actual data so you can see it's
actually modeling the data fairly well
then we can also decompose the signal
right so we have certain things like the
sine cosine pattern here for modeling
seasonality that's one component we have
these events here that are these spikes
we have the channel contribution in blue
in intercept term and these together
give you this sales data
just including this plot here because
we've just gotten it from Herbert Kubler
who just checked out the package and did
a pull request to add this so this is
just my
um love note to open source that like
you put stuff out there and then people
start working with it and contributing
back which is just amazing that that's
already happening
yeah these uh contribution plots so you
see that the the more you spend on the
x-axis
it's not that you get just more and more
on the y-axis there's a leveling off
effect
um a saturation effect
and of course you get posteriorist
because when a Bayesian framework it's
not just single estimates but whole
probability distributions and this helps
when assessing your uncertainty in these
estimates but also helps with uh
optimization for example there you
really want to take uncertainty into
account and since there's a simulation
study we can compare this to the true
return on ad spend and see that we
recover the trooper underlying
parameters pretty well
the other thing that I laid out before
was analyzing the effectiveness of a
marketing campaign so this is the next
task that Amy has to solve and here's
another example so we launched a new
product
and in in 2022 this was an example
um contributed by called Allen and we
see that sales have been pretty steadily
increasing since then which is great and
then here in February 2023 the marketing
team decided to run a
campaign to boost sales even further and
now the question is did that campaign
work yes or no
and well just visually it's kind of
difficult right I mean yeah maybe the
variants may be also increase so hard to
say just by gauging so obviously that's
just a question but actually not a
trivial statistical question because
usually what we would hope for if we're
like good scientists is a proper
experiment where we have a control group
where we didn't have the campaign and
one where we did give the campaign to
but we don't have that here
so this is the framework where of causal
analysis and quasi-experiments and this
is the other library that
um I'm very excited about called causal
Pi developed by Ben Vincent
and this is doing not only causal
analysis but in a Bayesian framework
which I think has many benefits so
you can see basically the logic behind
this just from these plots I hope it
makes sense is we have this path sales
data and we just fit a model to this and
then we predict what would have happened
if there was no intervention right and
that's why this is called a synthetic
control so we there is no real control
we're creating one
and so we just assume that like well it
would just continue like this and then
we can look at the residuals
and
then compare the residuals in the out of
sample essentially to compare the
difference between what a predict would
have happened and what actually happened
with the intervention
and then we can also just look at the
cumulative effect to really see what is
going on and we see that there's a very
strong effect that indeed it seems to
have made a difference and increased
sales even further
and also I'm I I'm not trying to code
but this is just a single line also to
do this and there's a lot of flexibility
in this so it's not just linear models
you can add covariates you can also use
scikit-learn models to do more complex
forecasts and synthetic controls and and
also different type of so this is a
synthetic control example but there's
different like different differences
within differences and there's a whole
zoo of things and we include many of
those
the last thing I wanted to show is
estimating customer lifetime value so
that's the other task and usually data
and this is actually the data underlying
the
plot I just showed it's not just sales
right those sales come from Individual
customers some are repeat buyers so we
want to get more insight into this and
we can use a they have somewhat obscure
names a beta Geo model
from the customer lifetime sub module in
privacy marketing and putting in data
like this like how many how often did
they buy when was the last time they
bought and how long have they been a
customer with us
for each customer
and then get for example over time let's
say they bought something here on day 31
what is the probability that this
particular customer that I use as an
example here is going to buy again
and as you can see over time we're
losing uh confidence that they will come
back right like customers churn all the
time and the longer we haven't seen them
the lower the probability that they will
come back
or assume now that they have actually
then bought again here so now we have
this confidence that well probably
they're gonna they're definitely still
alive and we're gonna just
um expect that they are gonna buy more
so this and many more analyzes you can
get insight into
which customers are driving your Revenue
which customers are at the highest risk
of churning and of course you also get
uncertainty in all of these because
we're in that Bayesian framework
now the last point I want to make is
this idea of combining models so again I
would like the way I laid it I was like
oh task a
tool a but the power comes from this
Unix Principle as I explained before
where usually in a company the goal is
not to minimize custom acquisition cost
or to maximize custom lifetime value but
rather to maximize Revenue right that's
really what we're after at the end of
the day and all these other things are
just
sort of waypoints on that path
because we do know that not all
marketing channels for example provide
equally valuable customers
they are different and really what we
want to do then is combine the media mix
and clv estimates to get a measure of
our profitability and not just these
other metrics and of course we can just
include customer causal impact analysis
into this as well and not only estimate
the custom the causal impact of our
marketing efforts onto sales but really
profitability right and this type of
thing so the way that I like to view
this is as just cogs and machine
and each tool is an individual clock but
the power comes from combining them
together
and also by combining these things
together there's this idea of
triangulation right so this is the thing
that we're after which we can't observe
but we have different data sets and
models that provide insight and if you
just have a single one right you have
much more you can say many fewer things
about this but if we triangulate and
combine many data sets and the insights
we can get an estimate that's much more
accurate
possibility is endless
so where are we going with this well
we're just getting started we plan to
add many additions if you follow our
Blog then
you have heard that we have hierarchical
models across channels and location
time varying parameters
Bayesian optimization dashboard but
really there's much more we can do so
asking everyone here to help us build
the most amazing toolbox out there
find the code on GitHub and here's some
more links if you want to know how this
can help you we also offer like a free
30-minute strategy session of how these
tools can most effectively help you so
thank you all for your questions for
attention and now we have time for
questions
[Applause]
Thomas we have a bunch of questions on
slido and I'll start with the most
popular one how is it possible to scale
Pi MC with growing data
and is there a distribution mode
I believe
can you ask again uh how is it possible
to scale Pi MC with growing data ah so
basic models have the
many people think that they're slow and
don't scale and that was definitely true
and it's becoming less and less true
because many of those scaling problems
have been solved so with pymc you we
have a Jax backend where you can run it
on the CPU but also the GPU so GPU
sampling we found to be especially
effective when having really large
models for really large data sets so
hundreds of thousands millions of data
points
not billions like deep learning for
example does so there are limits still
yeah so that is the first thing and then
we have another sampler called nut pie
that just came out that is usually
that's coded in Rust and then calling
into the number back end of time C and
there we're seeing even better speed UPS
on the CPU so uh yeah that's something
that is being actively worked on and we
already made a lot of progress on
see next question does Pi MC marketing
support CLTV projections for ad-based
business models for example mobile apps
um so I think that is something that you
can get out but I don't think we have a
particular function for it so there
would ask like do do pull requests we'd
love to have that yeah contribute
okay next question how do PI MC and Pi
Stan compare in terms of sampling
performance
so it used to be about the same
but now with the things I just mentioned
with the Jack sampling on GPU and the
nut sampling using rust and the number
back end we found in some benchmarks
that are not representative and not
um like
uh
yeah not done so properly and over such
a wide array of models that I can
confidently say it's always going to be
faster but we have seen
cases where it has been significantly
faster time C over Pi stem with these
news template additions cool
how do you validate and then recalibrate
your mmm models
so one key method of validating is the
posterior predictive check and then
that is the first step in what is called
the Bayesian workflow where you start
with simulation you look how well does
It capture my data you look for any
things that it doesn't capture yet and
then basically refine in a loop the
model iteratively and improve it until
you get a good fit
okay uh last question
um is pi MC able to generate the models
uh that generate graphic representations
of the models such as a mermaid diagram
um and is it for complex graphs really
easier to explain to stakeholders what's
going on
so maybe the question aims at this model
graph I showed with all these different
boxes so uh I mean yes so that comes
from PI MC proper so you're just like
it's a single function call and uses
graphis to create it and
so yeah that's a good question how
useful is that really I I don't
personally I don't really look at it I
know many people like it and I yeah it's
it is difficult to explain these models
uh to be honest and and that is one tool
that could be helpful is it
um super amazing to show someone like a
hundred boxes that are connected in
weird way not really so that's that's a
challenge and it's one of the things
better things we have but it's not a
cracked thing
great so that's all we have time for the
day
um give our speaker a round of applause
again thank you so much
[Applause]